So this is where we were
at the end last time.
Trying to decide when a high homo or a
low Lumo is unusual in its energy because
as the world is things
like to be in low energy,
we'll talk about that later.
Why that's so,
but that means that electrons tend to
be in the occupied, the low occupy,
the low energy orbitals and
not the high energy orbitals.
So that empty orbitals are almost always
higher than any occupied orbitals.
So if you want to get good energy match
and therefore mixing and therefore
bonding, right, the occupied
orbital that you're interested in,
it must be unusually high and the
vacant orbital must be unusually low.
So the task we have is to recognize what
orbitals should be unusually high and
what ones should be unusually low.
And if we can find the unusual ones,
then we'll know what's reactive.
Be able to identify functional groups.
Okay,
so unusual compared to what?
Compared to normal occupied and vacant
orbitals that is in organic chemistry or
most kinds of chemistry,
actually a carbon, carbon,
carbon hydrogen bonds are occupied
orbitals not unusually high.
There are standard of usual and the
anti bonds corresponding anti bonds are
unusual are the usual,
uh, vacant orbitals.
So what can make things unusually low
are unusually high when the valence Shell
orbitals that if they bonded, would go
down and up, don't bond with anything,
don't mix with anything, then
there'll be unusual. Second,
if the overalls don't overlap,
then they don't go down and go up.
Third,
if you have an unusual atomic orbital,
these are made of carbon
and hydrogen going down.
But if you start with something that's
unusual, unusually high, or unusually low,
then the things that come from it will
be unusually high or unusually low.
And finally electrical charge.
So right at the end,
last time we were looking
at the first example,
unmixed valence,
shell atomic orbitals.
So we saw that the simplest of all acids,
h plus of course is unusually,
it would,
if it were occupied, it would be
unusually high for an occupied orbital,
right?
Because it hasn't gone down,
but it's vacant and it's unusually low
for a vacant orbital because it hasn't
gone up and so on with these others.
And unshared pair on nitrogen
or a little less so on oxygen.
A vacant orbital on Boron that's not
bonding with anything is an unusually low
Lumo.
Even though orbitals on Boron are not
unusually low because the nuclear charge
isn't very big for something
that's using a, uh,
a second and equals to quantum
level orbitals valence orbitals,
it's an unusually low chart
nuclear charge for that.
So the orbitals are unusually low. Uh,
pardon me, are unusually high in energy,
not being attracted by more protons,
but it's low for a vacant orbital
if it hasn't mixed with anything.
Okay. And finally, notice that
some of these are charged.
H plus plus means that's a good
place to put an electron, right?
So unusually low, oh, pardon me. Oh,
H minus unusually high because
of the negative charge.
Ch three minus especially high.
So this slide also shows the fourth
point that electrical charge makes a
difference on the how normal
occupied and vacant orbitals are.
Okay?
Uh,
so these unusually low vacant orbitals
are acids like h plus unusually high
occupied orbitals are basis like oh h
minus as we just showed on the previous
slide.
That means that you can mix the high
homo of Ooh minus with the low Lumo of h
plus and two electrons,
the ones that were on the Oah minus go
down and energy. And that makes a bond.
And our notation for showing that is to
draw a curved Arrow and it gives water.
Now think carefully about
what a curved Arrow means.
It's not the same as a straight arrow.
A curved Arrow designates
a shift of electron pairs.
It doesn't show that this
Adam moves from here to here.
It shows that a pair of electrons shifts
and that pair of electrons goes from
being on the oxygen to being between
oxygen and hydrogen to form the bond.
So you start the curved Arrow where the
electron pair is at the beginning and
you end the Arrow put its point where
it's going to be in the product, right?
So it's not showing that an
atom moves from here to there.
It's showing that the electrons that
were formerly on oxygen are now between
oxygen and hydrogen.
The effect of that is of course to
pull the hydrogen to the oxygen,
but that's not what's
being shown by the Arrow.
What's being showed by the Arrow is how
the electrons are moving and our picture,
okay,
so there's a case.
Now here's another base with the same
acid and we'd draw a curved Arrow there
and show making an ammonium
ion out of ammonia.
Or we could use the same
base with a different acid,
the low vacant orbital of Bh three and
draw the same curved Arrow and make this
an ion.
Make the bore on oxygen bond.
Or we could start with
completely different ones.
We could start with ammonia,
not o h minus,
not Arrhenius is acid.
A radius is based, but ammonia
not Arrhenius acid, h plus,
but be h three but it's
exactly the same reaction.
The high homo mixes with the low
Lumo to form a new bond. Okay,
so that's what curved arrows show.
And don't confuse it by trying to draw
molecules or atoms moving and showing the
curved air. If you want to show a movie
and draw some other kind of Arrow draw,
a dotted arrows are a straight arrow
or a wiggly arrow or something.
But the curved arrows have
a very specific meaning.
Now, the, the second, uh,
reason that things could be unusually
high or low is because they don't have
much overlap. Notice in the first case,
it was just an extreme case of that.
There was no overlap at all.
The orbitals were just there.
But even though the orbitals
are mixed with something else,
if the overlap is poor,
they haven't changed very much.
They still look very much like
they did originally. Right?
So a good example of not having
very good overlap is decide,
decide, overlap of p
orbitals. The Pie overlap.
You remember from looking at those
curves of amount of overlap for different
orbitals versus distance. The
Pie overlap isn't very big. So,
even though the,
uh,
the P orbitals start a little
higher on carbon than they do on a,
uh,
on hydrogen or, or normal bonds of
carbon that have s character in them,
they start a little higher, but
they don't mix very much. Right.
So the,
the Pi or bundle is unusually high and
the Pi Star anti-bonding orbital is
unusually low because they didn't
go down or up very much. Okay.
Now,
which of those do you think is more
remarkable in its highness or lowness?
Which do you see?
So for this reason,
the carbon carbon double bond could
behave either as an acid or as a base,
right?
Hi.
Occupied orbital makes it a base low
vacant orbital makes an acid and indeed
does have both kinds of reactivity.
But which do you think is more pronounced?
Which would be more familiar?
How high the occupied one is
or how low the vacant one is.
Lucas, what do you say hello?
The Bacon. And why do you say so?
Because electrons have to
move into a position
as close as possible.
Yeah.
But on the other hand,
the electrons of the pie want
to move into something else.
There are lots and lots and
lots of electrons. Oh No.
Well there are lots of, there even more
vacant Oracle's than there are electrons.
Right,
because you also have story in
electronics like in a storable private.
Let's just at the
picture. Yeah, Catherine.
I think the
farther away from [inaudible].
Wow. The Homo is further
above the normal bonds.
Then the Lumo is below
the normal anti bonds. Why
can't hear it very well?
Because the P orbitals started a
little off cause they started. Yeah,
a little higher.
Right.
So most reactions that will study or at
least many reactions that will study of
the carbon carbon double bond.
It's reactive because of the high homo,
not because of the low lube oil.
Although there are cases where
the low Lumo makes it reactive,
but it's this Pi orbital here that makes
it particularly remarkable because they
started a little high.
Okay.
So the high homo makes
it unusually reactive.
Now how bout the C O Double Bond?
Right.
So it starts with the same
p orbital on the carbon,
which has pi overlap.
Therefore not much.
Shifting up and down was
a p orbital of oxygen,
which of course is lower than that of
carbon because of the higher nuclear
charge.
Which of these will be most unusual?
Somebody got a suggestion.
So what would you think the characteristic
reactivity of a CEO double bond?
Would it be reactive mostly as a high
Hobo that is as a base or mostly as a low
Lumo, which is more unusual compared
to what we compare things with
Andrew.
Why this is further away and why is it
further down compared to what we usually
compare?
Why does the
Pies Star C Double Bondo?
Why does,
why is that orbital so very
low? One reason, pardon me,
one reason it's low is because the overlap
isn't very much so it didn't go up so
much. Right. That's the same
true that cc double bond,
but what's special about
the CEO? Double Bond. Yeah,
because of it.
Bad Energy match,
right.
It didn't go up very much from the carbon
or down very much from the oxygen,
but the average is low
that it starts from,
so it's an what's special
here is the, the, the,
the Pi is not so unusual,
not so far from here,
but this one Pi star
is very far from here.
So what should make a carbonyl,
uh, especially reactive,
is it's low vacant orbital because of
poor overlap and that it started with an
oxygen unusually low
orbital atomic orbital.
Okay.
We saw another example here.
There's three membered.
Carbon ring is unusually reactive
for a carbon carbon bond.
That is the electrons in that carbon
carbon bond are not shifted down so much
and the anti bond is not shifted up so
much as a normal carbon carbon bonds.
Why?
What's special about the bonds
and the three membered ring,
Kevin?
Oh their bet.
And what does that mean? Yeah, but,
but their bet.
So what
does it overlap as well? So it
doesn't go up and down as much? Right?
So another example of poor overlap.
Okay.
Or You could have an unusual atomic
energy or in the molecular orbital,
for example. How about
a CF single bond? Right?
So the overlap can be perfectly good.
It's a regular old sigma bond straight on,
right?
But the fluorine starts very low.
There's bad energy match.
So the Pi Star isn't so very different
from a vacant orbital on carbon,
unusually low as a vacant orbital.
So it should act as an acid.
Things that have high homos should come
up and react with. With that, uh, uh,
sigma star of CF,
it's an unusually low Lumo.
Can you think of what
the flip side of that,
how could you have something like this?
A carbon bonded to something that for the
same or analogous reason would have an
unusually high occupied orbital.
What would you want the
carbon to bond with?
She an elephant. Lithium. Why?
Lithium
can cause you looked at the PowerPoint.
Why Lithium
is
easy for the barons electronically
to be given the right. Why?
Because it would be stable
as a get request. Why?
Because that's restating the same thing,
right?
What's different about lithium?
Why are orbitals on lithium as an atom
unusually high in energy compared to
carbon?
Hydrogen.
Catherine
has, it has a low nuclear charge, right?
It's right at the left end of the table.
Okay,
so it does,
it's orbitals aren't very stable
because it doesn't have very low,
very high nuclear charge.
So it's a high energy and that,
and therefore it has bad energy match.
Or it could have been lithium that I
drew here. I happened to draw Boron,
which is for the same reason a
lower nuclear charge than carbon.
Therefore, higher energy is an
atomic orbital when they mix.
What's special here is the
occupied orbital sigma,
right? Which is unusually high
because the average started. Hi.
Okay, so we, so boron,
you may remember that in the first slide
we showed boron had a vacant orbital,
right? That p orbital on Boron
is vacant, unusually low.
Therefore what?
Acid or base,
okay,
unusually low vacant orbital,
which does that make it acid? So
Bh three should be an acid, right?
But what I just showed you is what? Shy
on the previous slide. We'll go back.
It has a high, unusually high homo BH
three. So what does that make it shy?
Making a debate.
So is it an acid or a base?
Okay.
Wilson. It's both. And
what does that suggest?
If the same molecule is
both an acid and the base,
what do acids react with?
So what if the same molecules,
an acid and a base,
it's going to react with itself.
Two with the molecules will
react with one another. Okay. At,
that's why you can't do a
crystal structure of Bh three
cause BH three becomes B
two h six let's look at how it happens.
So there's the low Lumo that
makes BH three and acid.
What's the High Homo?
What's the high homo of Bh three
in localized terms,
I don't mean these big things
that go over the whole molecule.
It's the Bh Bond, right? Which was
poorly matched and energy and so on.
So there it's noticed that the BH
bonding electrons are big on hydrogen.
Small on Boron. We saw
that last lecture. Okay.
So they should overlap like this.
Right?
And the vacant orbital on
B h three should stabilize,
or the vacant orbital on the B should
stabilize these high energy electrons in
the Bh bond.
But now you could imagine many different
orientations of the top molecule that
would allow overlap.
Do you know why I chose
this particular orientation?
Which one as the acid in
which one is the base?
The one on the bottom of the
vacant orbital act as an acid.
The one on the top back.
That is a base.
So what other possibility is there
you Andrew,
there also as you can reverse the roles,
Aha, you can have. So that
would make notice. Incidentally,
what I forgot to mention here is that
there are three nuclei being held together
by that pair of electrons.
Now originally the top molecule that
pair of electrons mostly on hydrogen,
but partly on Boron,
held the hydrogen and the Boron together.
Now that same pair of
electrons is attracted is,
is helping form a bond with a boron,
the bottom boron.
So in fact,
that's an unusual kind of bond because
it's bonding three nuclei together,
not just to,
it's doing double or perhaps triple duty.
So we need a new symbol to talk about
such bonds and a reasonable one would be a
bond that looks like that.
It's a y bond.
We could make it blue.
Okay.
But now we have as you and just said,
the vacant orbital on the top and the
high occupied orbital on the bottom and
they can do exactly the same thing.
So we have two of these three center,
two electron bonds,
right?
Two electrons holding three
atoms together. Right?
Or we can draw it that way.
Right.
And that's the structure of B two h six
two of the pairs of electrons are each
bonding three atoms together instead of
two.
Any questions about this?
Yeah,
Alison dotted line.
The dotted just means
it's a little different.
You could draw the solid
why if you want to.
There's no really standard
notation for that,
but it's clear what it means.
It's just that a pair of electrons is
being shared among three nuclei rather
than two. And their electron
density is correspondingly.
If you did a different density Mac map,
if you could do an x ray of this,
you'd expect electron density to build
up in the middle of all three. Yeah.
Claire,
let's me see like stupid,
but we've talked about some base and
although Lumo talks about as an acid is
unoccupied, so it's, I mean
I think about it like this,
it's sort of receiving electronics,
right?
But generally basis are supposed to
receive a lecture on this instead of acids
and no, you've got it backwards. Yeah.
Cause I
h plus is an acid,
right?
So it obviously can't
give up electrons there.
Adobe electrons and
acid accepts electrons.
Okay.
Think about it a little bit in the
privacy of your room and you'll see that,
okay,
I can
only happen here because of the geometry.
Yeah. And then to get, to get that,
you have to have overlap. So if
you didn't have, if that top,
if the top Bh three were
oriented so that the Bh bond,
we're vertical in the Boron
was way up at the top,
it wouldn't overlap the other one. So
you have to, you always to get a bond,
you have to have overlap because otherwise
the orbitals don't mix and you just
have the original orbitals as we've seen,
this is kind of fun.
During carnival it's kind
of been very common. No,
it's not very common because there are
not many vacant or low really low energy
vacant orbitals running around,
right? Boron is a very special case,
but a lithium can do the same thing,
but lithium doesn't have energies,
orbital energies as low as those of
Boron because it doesn't have as big a
nuclear charge. So Boron is particularly
good at getting this kind of thing.
And this answers the puzzle about Lewis
structures that we raised in lecture too,
about what, how can be h three
react with Bh three right?
That's how it does it by
making three center bonds. Now,
here's the true and false quiz
on the basis of what you know.
Is it true that low energy molecular
orbitals result in bonding,
true or false?
I don't think you've trusted me anymore.
We've been saying that when you
get those low orbitals right,
things come together. You've got a
low orbital that results in a bog,
lots of overlap.
Can't talk you into it.
Go ahead.
That's false.
What makes a bond is lowered energy.
Orbitals it's when things come together
and the electrons get more stable.
It's not how low they are.
It's how much they're lowered
by the coming together
because then pulling apart,
they have to go back up again.
So it's not whether they're high or low,
it's whether they get lowered.
Okay.
Now compared to what?
What do they have to get lower compared to
you and Joe?
Kind of like how in your winning
gold did it, showed the antibody,
you can say something in
fewer words than that.
What do you compare to when you say
energy is lowered and that makes a bond?
What's it lowered compared to
Christopher DMC, their standard
states? Uh, the, well, yes,
but it could,
it wouldn't necessarily be between atoms.
It could be between two molecules like
BH three with BH three what it's about.
You're right,
what it's lowered compared to is the
things that was before they came together.
Right now these things before they came
together, one of them had electrons.
One didn't. Those might
have been very high. Right?
So they came together,
the electrons went substantially down,
but still aren't so very low.
They could have been very low
energy orbitals to begin with,
but not gone down very much.
Okay.
Because there was bad
overlap say so these,
even though they're lower than the ones
we talked about first would not be so
bonding.
It's these that we're bonding because
they came down a lot when the mixing
happened.
So it's lowering compared to what?
Compared to the separated components
before you made this bond. Right.
So when things come together and that
results in the electrons going way down in
energy, that's a strong bond.
Yes. Genuine part of it.
Well, that's what we're going to have to
learn. That's a question of Lore, right?
And it has to be at least enough to
overcome the fact that when they come
together, other electrons, other orbitals
are filled orbitals are overlapping,
which is net repulsive.
So it may not be that there's
an absolute criterion, right?
It may be that if there are a lot of
other things opposing the coming together,
filled orbital with filled orbital,
then you have to have on you
really enormous going down.
So you can't make a simple question,
simple answer to that. But we're,
we'll learn as we see examples.
Okay,
so now Homo Lumo mixing for
reactivity and resonance.
So reactivity means between molecules.
So far we've been talking mostly about
Adam's coming together and forming a
bond. But molecules have high
orbitals and low orbitals.
As in the case of Bh
three, the Bh was, uh,
was a molecular orbital or if
not an atomic orbital, right?
So when things come together,
orbitals are orbitals.
If you have an unusually high energy and
then an unusually low energy and they
overlap and go down, that makes a
bond. So that's between molecules.
But it turns out that what resonance is
is Homo Lumo mixing within a molecule.
Now you might say the molecules
have certain molecular orbitals.
How can you mix them?
Right?
The idea is that we made our first
analysis on the basis of localized orbital
sigma sigma star here,
Sigma Sigma Star here.
Not these big Kolodny things
that go over the whole thing,
but it may be that this sigma sigma star
and this Sigma Sigma Star are near one
another and overlap so that when we made
our initial analysis and looked only at
this and only with this,
we didn't take into account that this
one might interact with this one and give
still lower energy when that
kind of thing is important.
That's when you have to draw
other resonance structures.
And I'll show you an example,
but first I'm going to show you reactivity
and then we'll go on to residence.
Okay, now let's look at the
frontier orbitals four h f
okay,
so it has four valence electron pairs
and five valence atomic orbitals,
two s two p, x, Y, Z on Fluor,
on fluorine and the one s on hydrogen.
And and four pairs of electrons.
So they're going to be four occupied
orbitals and these are what the,
this is what the lowest or, but it looks
like what does, what does it look like?
Well,
it's a two s orbital,
the one s being the core on flury
but it's made up of atomic orbitals.
Is it exactly a two s of fluorine?
Does it look like a sphere on fluorine?
Alison, you're shaking hit your head.
And how would they get a little distorted?
What did we mix with the F orbital?
A little bit of the one s on hydrogen.
It's mostly the F on flury. Why?
Cause the flu rates way down in energy.
So the best the nation is mostly this,
but you can see that it's
a little bit egg shaped,
a little bit drawn out
toward the hydrogen. Okay,
so it's mostly a two s of or a fluorine,
but a little bit of one s on hydrogen
right now here's the next one.
What's that mostly?
Can you see
Tyler a site that would say it too.
It looks like the Tupe on Fleury.
Does it look exactly like a two P on
Florida or is it just hard for you to see
that it's not?
It's very simple.
The blue one might be a bit,
yeah,
the blue one is a little bit bigger
because it's got a little bit of the one s
of hydrogen lowering the energy
of the two P of fluorine.
Okay.
And now the next two orbitals are these,
what are those?
Okay, Steve, what did you say?
They're the two P Y and two
PC. A fluorine. Do they make,
why is their hydrogen in those two?
Why not?
Ah, they're orthogonal.
It's a pie versus a sigma.
There's no overlap,
therefore no mixing.
So those are the occupied orbitals
and the two p's have the same energy.
Okay.
And then remember they're going to be
five molecular orbitals and now you make
the last one,
which is going to have another
node with the leftovers.
What's leftover after we made
the occupied or, but also
what's it mostly leftover?
We used up the two P's of fluorine to
make those homos. Those were pure. Right?
But what was leftover
from from the bottom,
we use very little of one s on hydrogen
and there's a little bit of two p
fluorine and two s Florian that
we didn't use in the bottom ones.
So they're back in the top. So what
we have is mostly a one s on hydrogen,
but a little bit of some kind
of sp hybrid on fluorine.
Is that clear to everyone? So that's
the, that's the vacant orbital.
Is it unusual energy?
That vacant orbital?
It's, it's low. Is it unusually
low? Okay. Do you have an idea?
What kind of criteria do we
have for whether an orbital
should be unusually low?
What do we look for?
Overlap. Energy match. How
about this case? Good overlap.
White. Good overlap. It's a hybrid.
Robert on fluorine pointed right
toward a hydrogen. Good overlap.
How about the energy match,
Kate?
Sure,
sure, sure. It's good or it's bad.
One of them is hydrogen.
What's the other one?
Where's flooring compared to hydrogen?
Why?
Right. Okay. Good. Energy match or
bad energy match? Not very good.
So you don't get much mixing.
And you know that already by looking at
the picture because you didn't mix it
very much.
It's almost all one s of hydrogen.
So it's unusually low for a sigma star.
It didn't go up very much from hydrogen.
So indeed now it's got an
unusually low vacant orbital.
What does that make it an acid or a base?
It's an acid.
Are you surprised that Ahf is an acid?
Why?
What's his name?
Hydrofluoric acid.
And that's what makes it an acid.
A radius would say it's an acid because
it gives up h plus we say it's an acid
because it's an unusually low
vacant orbital right now here. Uh,
so notice that those three are
made up of three atomic orbitals,
the one s of hydrogen,
the two s of fluorine,
and the two p a p two p orbital,
a fluorine,
and they're in different
mixtures in three of these.
Usually we've looked at just two things,
right?
There's one Adam atomic
orbital and another one.
And they mix right a pair here.
There are three going in to
give three molecular orbitals,
but still you can see quite easily
why they should be the way they are.
Why the bottom ones are almost pure
fluorine and the top one is almost pure
hydrogen.
Uh,
okay. And so that top one
is sigma star, the Lumo,
the unusually low Lumo look us,
be sure that the one is of
like the low nuclear charge.
Hydrogen is going to be that much
different from that really highly of their
charge to us in Florida.
Yeah.
This you have to learn and I'm going to
show you very soon how we can tell that
kind of thing.
Yeah.
Okay. There's a different picture that
was made in 1973 of the same thing.
These pictures were drawn just a year
or two ago, right? But this, this is,
you can see the same thing.
It's drawn at a different contour level.
It was based on a different calculation,
but you can see it's the same thing.
And we'll notice that.
How many nodes does this thing have
that are clearly visible to nodes?
Right? Between the H and f,
that one is anti-bonding.
Right?
When they came together,
they canceled in the middle rather than
reinforcing, there's another node there,
but notice that that didn't have
anything to do with the bonding that was
already there in the atomic
orbital you started with,
so it didn't have anything
to do with lowering.
It didn't have anything to do with whether
the thing was bonding or anti-bonding.
The pink node had to do with whether
it was bonding that came when they came
together. Right. It's an
unfair, it's unfavorable,
so it's better for them to come apart,
but if they come apart,
you don't do anything with the blue note.
It's still there. It's part of the Adam.
Okay, so you have to recognize
that there are two kinds of nodes.
There are nodes that were there already,
atomic orbital nodes,
and they're ones that are
associated with the coming together,
and that's what makes something bonding
or anti-bonding this particular case,
it's anti-bonding. Okay,
now let's look instead of h,
let's look at ch three f.
Sam
because you have occupied orbitals and
then you have vacant orbitals and the
ones you're interested in are the lowest
of the vacant and the highest to the
occupied at this border between
occupied and vacant orbitals.
Okay, so this one has seven
valence pairs of electrons.
So you're going to occupy seven
orbitals and here's what they look like.
The seven that are occupied,
what's the very lowest one? Mostly
it's the two s of fluorine,
right? And what's the next one?
Well, it's ch bonds all
mixed together, right?
But also a little bit of a Pr,
but alon fluorine,
it has the blue sort of toward the front
and a little bit of that red behind as
part of the p orbital on flooring.
So it's a mixture of the
ch bonds and of the, uh,
of the p orbital on fluorine.
And then we have these others,
some of them coming and payers.
And those are the homos
because we have seven occupied.
And let's look at them a
little more closely and
compare them with each one with
the one beneath it. And I'll draw
another picture too for of that.
Older kind for making this comparison
and we're interested in what is it that
went together to make these orbitals
and why is one lower in energy and the
other higher?
So what do you see on the top orbital?
Say this one here at the top left.
What's that made up of?
What is it on the left side?
Sophie,
what would you say the orbital
is on the left side of that.
Okay,
right. This part here
is a two P pi, right?
Orbital of fluorine. Now what's this
thing on the right here? The Dash,
the bit down here.
If you just saw that without any of the
rest of it, what would you say that was?
It's more, it's more than a one s
on hydrogen that would be spherical.
It's at a certain contour.
The CH bond.
You see that? So this is, this
is electron density in here,
bonding between Cnh and these two on the
top are little bits of ch bonds as well
mixed together.
So what this orbital is,
is a mixture between some
combination of ch bonds on the right
and the p orbital of fluorine on the left.
Now,
is it a favorable or an
unfavorable combination of
the fluorine orbital with the
Cah orbitals.
This one up here is the interaction
between the fluorine orbital and the Cah
orbitals bonding or anti-bonding.
Becky, do you have an idea?
Are they building up electron density
in between or having a node in between?
There's a node in between,
so that's anti-bonding.
What's the orbital on the bottom?
This one,
that's the same components,
but it's the bonding combination.
So this is the favorable combination
of those and this is their unfavorable
combination.
So this lower energy when is favorable
and the upper energy is unfavorable
combination.
How about here and here?
Can you what that is?
What's on the left here that that that
lump of red and this lump of Blue Eric.
Okay.
Here, here in this thing is made. That
is a, it's very complicated. Okay.
Will you agree on that? Okay, but
part of it is part on the left,
there's a red lump in behind
and a blue lump in front.
You can see it maybe more clearly here,
red behind and blue in front
surrounding the green fluorine atom.
What is that?
Orbital at atomic orbital.
Can't hear it right away.
It's The p orbital on fluorine that's
pointed more or less toward you. Okay,
so this is a PR battle of flury
that's mixing with ch bonds here,
right? In fact, it's the same
thing as this turned on its side.
Okay,
so this is the bonding combination built
up between the fluorine in the CHS.
This is the anti-bonding one with a
node between the fluorine in the CHS.
So here we have a node in this bottom one,
but that node came from
the atomic orbitals.
That's what made it a p
orbital here on fluorine,
that when you don't get rid of,
if you pull the fluorine away,
that doesn't have anything
to do with the bonding.
That's just an atomic orbital node.
Right on the top.
You again have the same atomic orbital
node because it's the same p orbital
that's involved.
But what about the top Sam?
There's another node that one,
and that's an anti bonding node,
right?
The electrons in that orbital
would get a lower in energy if the,
if you broke the bond,
if the fluorine came away.
So the pink nodes are the ones we're
interested in. The anti-bonding nodes,
not the ones that are just part
of the atomic orbital. Okay?
Now, uh, we're getting
to Lucas's question.
So this thing down here is made up of
fluorine and c h the one here is made up
of fluorine and Cah,
right?
This is the favorable combination
and this is the unfavorable combination.
So you get it right.
So here are the two of them.
They come together when the f comes
up to the methyl right and you get a
favorable one and an unfavorable one,
but the fluorine and the Cah is
may not be at the same energy.
How do you know which one's lower?
That's your question.
Is the fluorine lower or is the
ch lower or are they about same?
Now,
how are we going to tell
if the fluorine is lower
and they come together?
What does the lower one look like?
Mostly flury.
If the floor higher and they come
together, what does the low one look like?
Mostly Ch, right? So by
looking at how big these are,
we can tell which one is lower.
So when we look here, uh, we,
uh, we, we see that here the,
I would say they're pretty
similar left to right.
There's not much difference between a
two p orbital on fluorine and ch Sigma
bonds. Not much difference, but
to the extent they're different.
I would say looking at this,
that the ch is a little bigger here and
the fluorine is a little bigger here.
Would you say that?
So,
which is lower a ch sigma bond
or the P orbital of fluorine?
Ch sigma bond would be a little
lower than Fleury. Not much though.
Pretty similar.
So they're about the same as we say.
But if you have to make a choice,
the ch is a little bit lower in energy,
the flu reads a little higher.
Okay.
Uh,
now there's also a vacant orbital
made up with the leftovers here.
Some of the leftovers. And what's that?
Let's look at a different picture of it.
So this has three nodes that are obvious.
There's one that's near the fluorine atom,
a node plane that goes back the
furthest to the left. Everyone see that?
Is that a bot anti-bonding node
or is that an atomic orbital node?
That's part of the Fleury
at atomic orbitals of some
hybrid on fluorine. Right?
And the same is true at the Cah end.
There's a node that's an atomic
orbital node of the carbon, right?
But what's important
between those other two is what's between
the fluorine and the carbon and the ch
three and that's anti-bonding so that the
Lumo is a sigma star anti bond between
C and methyl.
And why is it unusually low?
The question is whether the
Lumos should be unusually low.
Why is it unusually low?
Is the overlap bad?
No, the overlap's good. Did hybrids
pointed right toward one another?
But what makes it low in energy?
So you know, I'm not giving
you specific problems on this,
but look over those things and run your
brain as to those four different things
that make orbitals unusually
high or unusually low
because that's what you'll be
doing next week.
When you're doing these wikis,
each of you decide some functional group.
Why is it functional?
What makes it unusually higher,
unusually low, or maybe neither, right?
Why is the c f bond more properly
the CF sigma star or orbital?
The anti-bonding orbital.
Why is it unusually low
compared to what?
What do you compare to
a ch bond?
How come C F is lower for the sigma star?
Alex?
Pardon me? Yeah. The fluorine is
really low. Their average is very low,
so the vacant doorbell is unusually
low. It didn't go up much, right?
Where have you seen that before?
H f
the previous slide. Ahf was exactly
the same. It's an acid. Remember Kate,
you helped us with that.
It's an acid because of the bad energy
match between fluorine and hydrogen.
This is the same thing,
but it's the bad energy match
between fluorine and carbon. Okay,
so ch ch threeF is an acid for the
same reason that HF is an acid.
All right, there's the
low Lumo of Ahf, right?
It's got that same anti-bonding node shy.
Why is there no,
maybe
it just happens that it
worked out that way. Oh,
it's let's screw hydrogen is one
s that makes it unusually low,
but it doesn't have very
big nuclear charge. Carbon
has a higher nuclear charge,
but you're talking two s and two P and
it turns out those just cancel out.
If that hadn't been the case,
organic chemist,
like if if Boron happened
to match hydrogen,
then maybe our organic chemistry
would be, but be Boron, hydrogen,
not carb ever be borrow hydrates,
not carbohydrates. Right?
But that's the way things are. So in
this picture, we do sell that. Actually,
there are other reasons it wouldn't be
boron because Boron has these vacant
orbitals and farms B two h six and so on.
But it just happens that that
cancellation works that way.
You just by looking at this picture,
we can say that, uh, ch three,
there's four mg magic because the rules
around Floreano much smaller than those
around, Oh, let's look at
the next slide here. Uh,
is it this one? No, we're
going to get to that.
If you looked at ones that
were very badly mismatched,
then the favorable and unfavorable
combinations would be very dramatic.
And actually you've already
seen that in HF. Okay?
Uh, we have one minute
to start this. Okay.
So we're going to look at how c
h three f behaves like h f right?
Both of them are acids.
So first we'll look at HF,
and next time we'll go on to see
h three f. So here's, here's HF.
So you have to bring,
here's a veilleux low vacant orbital.
We've talked about that ad nauseum.
Okay,
now you want to get good
overlap from what direction?
We'll another orbital come in order
to get good overlap without the nuclei
getting too close together.
Obviously it'll come from are often
the right where this orbital is big,
where you can get a lot of overlap
without getting close to the nuclei.
So if you had something with a high energy
pair of electrons that would come and
it would overlap from the right,
something like Ooh, minus,
and you draw curved Arrow
to show those electrons,
the high homo of Ooh,
minus being stabilized by
the vacant orbital of HF.
And how would you draw the curved Arrow?
Where would it start? Where would it end
to show the electrons have h
minus forming a bond with Oih Bod?
You start from the pair of electrons
that you're talking about and you'd end
between h and o,
right?
But that means this is really important.
That means you're putting
electrons putting electron
density into this orbital,
right?
What effect does putting electrons
in that orbital have on the HF bond?
Okay.
Okay. The curved arrows,
blah, blah. We did that.
Sherwin,
it's what? What do you call that? Orbital.
What's the name of the orbital that
we're putting electrons into oneness?
It's Sigma Star. It's mostly one s
on hydrogen, but it's Sigma Star.
What does star mean?
What does it mean if you put
electrons in the bond? Double Braids,
right? It has that anti-bonding
node, so electrons that go into that,
we'll get more stable if the bond breaks.
So we're going to draw
another curved Arrow
like that.
So we make a new bond between Hno,
but we lose the bond between h and f.
So there's our product
that's an acid base reaction,
and it showed HF acting as an acid,
not because it gave h plus h
plus never appears in here.
Right? What happened is you make a
bond and break a bond to the hydrogen.
So it's an acid base reaction and the
same thing will show next time happens
with ch three f.
Okay.